ist bei den vorschlägen was will ich was
es geht und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute ehrt bestimmten
letzten tagen die videos gesehen haben
instagram bestimmt mein tag ist ja quasi
zu neuer trend ist auf youtube gibt und
ich dachte mir eigentlich neueste idee
aber so bestimmt einen tag oder mein
leben nicht jeder schon gemacht deswegen
machen wir das heute ähnlich aber anders
und zwar leute wird heute instagram ein
einkauf bestimmen ich werde auf amazon
gehen und werde mir von den leuten auch
in zusammen sagen lassen was ich suche
und b ob ich das dann kaufen muss oder
nicht und ich kaufte sie was er sagt und
ich weiß jetzt schon dass nichts gutes
bei rauskommen wird aber das prinzip ist
heute letzter okay leute ihr dürft jetzt
wie folgt mitbestimmen schick mir eine
direktnachricht mit dem ersten produkt
das ich suchen sollte also solch einen
toilettensitz suchen oder geranien
fehlen schmuck oder was ich suche das
sind dann dürfte entscheiden ob es kauft
oder nicht okay leute wir sitzen hier
wir sind auf amazon und die erste
nachricht war dass wir uns das dreirad
suchen sollen
die erste nachricht die wir überhaupt
bekommen haben kann von mir gesagt wir
sollen das urteil dazu ganz kurz ich
wollte nur kurz was wir auf dein hat
amazon start weiter
vier arten von hausen wie alt man kann
wirklich sein ich suche er sollte das
dreirad ist das teuer um gott oh mein
gott 300 euro sega übertreibung lässt
sich toll free aus oder ich setze jetzt
1 ord
wir uns besser auf 10 10 aus schicken
die leute mein handy hat den geist
aufgegeben dass das handy wechseln aber
wir haben die erste abstimmung seite
bereit letzter und zwar müsst ihr wissen
ob wir diese puppe kaufen soll oder
nicht ja oder nein ist aber immer so ein
fertiger wir warten jetzt gerade auf die
abstimmung zur so dieser kings of pop
nimmt es mir übel dass ich nicht action
kultfigur classics seine 300 euro wer
reaktoren selbst beschreibt also schon
okay bin gespannt ob die leute es
überhaupt wollen dass du die kaufen ja
okay wir schauen jetzt in die abstimmung
rein aber gucken was hier gesagt habt da
will ergebnis leute 72 prozent haben
gesagt wir sollen die saubere kaufen
klarer fall würde ich sagen dann wird es
auch gekauft das okay falls sie jetzt
irgendwie selbst jetzt noch mal die
abstimmungsergebnisse nachgeschaut sind
natürlich nur die kurzfristigen
abschlussergebnis das heißt kann was
anderes aufkommen aber wir müssen das
natürlich daran halten
das heißt du weißt ja so poppe clown
plüschfigur auf dreirad 100 prozent poly
perfekt genau das wollte ich heute
morgen holen in den einkaufswagen so
haben wir mist leute ja die abstimmung
eindeutig ich musste diese kaufen nicht
vielen dank dafür ihr könnt jetzt hier
hoch vision da kommen wir zu einem bild
kommentiert unter das bild was ich als
nächstes suchen sollten schneller wieder
auf das gekauft wird okay leute es gibt
weiterhin erstmal ab was sie mir
geschrieben haben und dieses bild hier
ein aktuelles bild der neueste kommentar
da ist eine okay ich sehe hier einen
kommentar leute von einem lisa such
einen wäschekorb ok oh ja ich nicht
immer so
markant wäschekorb 224 euro was geht
denn ab alter auf gar keinen fall
224 euro du warst du mal was raus du mal
was aus wofür sogar bestimmt ich würde
sagen als nächstes lassen über die leute
abstimmen ob wir 4 sterne und mehr oder
einen stern und mehr nehmen dass ich mir
auch die einstellung bekommen leute es
geht weiter
die nächste entscheidende treffen dürfte
könnt und müsst ist soll der wäschekorb
mindestens ein stern haben oder
mindestens vier ich glaube max ist der
meinung ein stellen reicht eigentlich
für meinen verein ihr könnt entscheiden
wahrscheinlich lang soll gehört also
juni erwarten ganz auf das
abstimmungsergebnis von 1 oder 4 stellen
wir schauen was noch so gibt hier und
verstehe nicht warum ein wäschekorb
hersteller songs heißt die mikrofone
leute wir haben auch hier wieder ein
ergebnis und ich muss sagen ich bin auch
ich bin positiv überrascht mindestens
vier sterne positiv bin ich jetzt nicht
überrascht du wirst mir so einen zu den
schlechtesten china welche gebühren für
34 euro ok weiß was mindestens vier
sterne kein problem für mich nur das
beste normal hat mir da oben ist ja
nicht einfach traumhaft und den nehme
ich sie jetzt oder nie
warum der und den zugang zu bestimmtem
anhin zügig aber nicht zu stellen also
geballte leute max hat zwei wäsche vor
ausgesucht für mich die er für eine gute
abstimmungsmöglichkeit hält und zwar
entweder den hier oben den weißen oder
die in schwarz grau nie fertig schöner
weil es über schwarz grau
hockey sebastian ich glaube die leute
haben in der zwischenzeit entschieden da
ist platz für einen wäschekorb flughafen
soll die sache ist leute ich brauche
halt wirklich gerade wäschekorb ich habe
meinen alten geschrottet verso
durchgebrochen um und ich werde aber
nicht welche kopf passt geht jetzt kann
ich sagen ich will nicht auf gar keinen
fall diesen fackeln wäschekorb bass
keyboard afag aber kommt voll geil hat
stand automatik das ist ein wäschekorb
wieso den verstand automatik gebäudes
bitte bitte schwarz grau bitte w80 zu
mein gott nicht schlecht kraft er warum
können die leute richtig versteht es
nicht ich dachte ich verarsche mich
jetzt übel leute aber ihr verabschieden
die kenn ich nicht wirklich gebrauchen
geil ist okay ich hab eine stop bestellt
so gut läuft und nicht jeder gute dir
hier hat man hier sieht man hier sieht
man auf jeden fall
in wohnzimmer gestellt wurden postshop
[Gelächter]
perfekte das sieht so gut aus also ist
so wenig foto geschafft da muss ich erst
mal dass nach dem start ist den rücksitz
fall ist die sein alter okay heute auch
das wäschekorb kapitel ist abgeschlossen
ja ich würde sagen dass ich hier jetzt
hoch ist ein anderes bild kommentiert da
was ich als nächstes suche soll max wey
da diesmal die lustigste einsendung aus
und damit entschied auch die käuferin
ich hab's gesehen die nächste abstimmung
ist ein gang nicht abstimmen soll eine
umfrage unter dem bild jetzt entscheidet
ihr gerade in diesem moment was hat
nichts gesucht wird aber diesmal
entscheidet nicht die erste anwendung
wäre langweilig manchmal gleich machen
sondern diesmal das max die vergehen
lustigste einsendungen den lustigsten
fortschritt auswählen und lustiges
das hier ist ein vorschlag den max
gerade noch nicht endgültig ausgegeben
aber der fall war
ein kumpel ostereier costumer spa war
doch nicht so schlimm nicht luca
kommentiert meist luca unser computer
dokumentiert dies xxl dh also quasi
einen übergrößen bh warum 60 mph ich
würde sagen wie du erscheinst den aus
also erstmal würde ich sagen lass das
mal nicht kaufen zumal keine aus der
reizvoller als das krank die leute das
kranke das funktioniert niemals größe im
bikini alltag hilft mit penny und diese
damen spitze des lebens und sexszenen
was passiert wenn dieses ding für einen
cent bestellt denkst du wirklich was
machen dass kein weiterer ausverkauf von
home bbv ok in einkaufswagen alter 1
cent wirklich wissen ob sie weise
irgendwie illegal die zulagen oder so
und die müssen wir loswerden
die leute haben es gemacht es ist
bestellt und jetzt sollten wir haben uns
auf jeden fall schon perfekt eingelenkt
was haben wir uns bestellt natürlich
hätten als flüchtlinge habe ich schon
länger gebraucht ich hab ich ein
wäschekorb und ein xxl
während es bei 38 euro oder so ist hier
oben 38 65 und wir können noch einen
abschluss machen ins programm darf war
sie noch mal entscheiden ob ich ein
produkt kaufe oder nicht alle letzte
entscheidung gibt es dich führt sagen
leute wir kommen jetzt einfach mal
vollkommen zu recht zum hunger kostüm
zurück das kann man auch gebrauchen so
was ich will ich will ja auch nicht böse
ist ja ich meine ich irgendwann wenn ich
auch mal einen job arbeiten wir für
bewerbungsgespräche mit einem humor
kostüm kommt per post direkt wow der
tumor person roma oder alternativ leuten
justin bieber pappaufsteller die bei den
vorschlägen beobachten das will ich auch
er weiß ganz genau so wird mit ganz
genau von den amazon hat bestimmt
sondern richtig holen ein einkaufskorb
analysiert und neue sachen vorstand der
der zerbricht wahrscheinlich alles klar
die beiden kosten auch ungefähr gleich
viel und jetzt wird zum letzten mal
instagram die große und ewigen mächtige
instanz dieser menschheit im jahre alte
ich muss jetzt ganz stark sein
die letzte abstimmung ist da und sie ist
zwischen einem und justin bieber
pappaufsteller jetzt abstimmen leute die
leute stimmen in diesem moment jetzt ab
ich will auf jeden fall
das war so geil alter diese gesichter
institute einfach nur sein leben
leute wir kommen zum wohl wichtigsten
entscheidungen des tages wird ist das
formal kostüm oder würdest justin bieber
pappaufsteller ich habe ganz klar gesagt
was mein favorit ist und wir eröffnen
die alles entscheidende story
[Musik]
die leute wollen den justin bieber
pappaufsteller sebastian musste jetzt
leben muss sich entschieden das video zu
machen ja heute in den einkaufswagen
leute hier haben wir die bestell
übersicht ich muss man natürlich meine
adresse zensieren und meine kontodaten
und mein ganzes leben hier alles gesehen
hier nochmal in den teams wir haben den
justin bieber wir haben in welche
sammler und wir haben keine abbilder
vorhanden und für den b herab scheiße
gelaufen und jetzt getrieben auf jetzt
kaufen leute ich habe bestellt ich habe
durchgezogen instagram hat meinen
einkauf bestimmt wird hier ein eigenes
unboxing video dazu haben wollt dann
habe ich gerne mal in die kommentare
macht sich seine beschreibung verlinkt
und wenn ihr noch mehr von mir sehen
wollt könnt ihr nochmal vollgas geht
aufdecken